RYAN LOREN: All
right, everybody.
We're here to welcome
Gordon Chambers.
I'm so happy to have you here.
It's been a long time coming.
And Gordon, for those
of you who don't know,
is probably one of the
best writers in existence.
That's just one man's
opinion, but that's mine.
And so I'm going to talk to you
a little bit about your writing
process and all of that.
But first, can you take
us back to the beginnings
and how you got started?
I know you've had
quite a background,
and just take us back.
GORDON CHAMBERS: It
began-- it was all a dream.
I used to read
"Word Up" magazines.
Give love to Brooklyn
and Biggie Smalls, y'all.
Brooklyn in the house?
AUDIENCE: Brooklyn!
GORDON CHAMBERS:
But I have lived
in Brooklyn for the
last 15 years or so.
But I was born in
the Bronx, but raised
in a wonderful community
called Teaneck, NJ.
And I think some
Teaneck people are here.
And I'm grateful for
my town, because it
was a town where there
were just a wonderful group
of supportive parents, my
parents, and music teachers.
And when I was in sixth
grade, I was writing songs.
I was given an assignment
to write a short story
about the book "Jonathan
Livingston Seagull."
And being the Libra
creative person that I am,
I said well, instead of writing
a short story, I wrote a song.
And I showed the
teacher the song.
And she said, well,
that's a really good song.
She said, why don't we teach
this to all the sixth graders?
And so she taught to
all the sixth graders.
And it was performed
in a sixth grade
assembly for all the kids.
And then later on
in high school,
I continued writing songs.
And one of my best
friends in high school
was murdered by her boyfriend.
Donyel Morton-- may
she ever rest in peace.
And after she passed, I
needed to do something
to process my feelings.
And I wrote a song
called "Always Be There."
And once again, I showed
it to some of the teachers
at the school, and they
were very moved by the song.
And I shared it
with her parents.
And one of the teachers
was a dance choreographer
at the school, Ms.
Miller-- and she
said, I'm going to choreograph
something to this song,
so that this will forever live
in the Teaneck Terpsichoreans
repertoire.
So she choreographed something.
And then other
students came forward.
We'll do a poem.
And then we'll do something.
So the birth of that song
created a whole evening
where 2,000 people
came to just give
creative remembrances of Donyel.
So I really felt like
God had chosen me
as a child to provide
songs that could inspire
and that could heal.
And so after that,
I went to college.
I went to Brown University,
kept on writing.
Then I took a job at
"Essence" magazine
and became the entertainment
editor of "Essence."
And I served in that
position for seven years.
And that was a great
networking place.
And so while I was
there hanging out,
I met a wonderful
lady, Phyllis Hyman,
AUDIENCE: Oooh.
GORDON CHAMBERS: Who's
also-- may she rest in peace.
And she took me under her wing.
And I also met Queen Latifah.
And so Queen Latifah
and Phyllis Hyman
were the first two superstars
who not only became friends
but mentors and had me write
on some of their albums.
And then I met other people
like producers Barry Eastman
and Dave Hall and
then started writing
some of the songs that became
number one hits and sold
millions of records.
God is good.
So some of those songs include
Anita Baker's "I Apologize,"
Brown Stones' "If
You Love Me, Say It,"
the theme from "Set It Off,"
"Missing You" by Brandy, Tamia,
Gladys Knight and Chaka Khan,
as well as cuts for Whitney
Houston, Tamia, Brandy,
Gladys Knight, Marc Anthony,
Patti LaBelle, Chaka Khan, Chaka
Khan and 75 recording artists.
Thank you, Lord.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN LOREN: Great.
I am curious about this.
And I ask other artists too, but
can you talk about the process
you use to write
and how it happens.
Is it different every time?
Do you create conditions
that make it happen?
Or what do you do?
GORDON CHAMBERS: I have
different writing process.
It just depends what it is.
I mean, some songs of
mine, I write at the piano,
and they tend to
be more ballads.
But a lot of times,
collaborations
are about opposites attracting.
So a lot of my songs
have been written
with producers that were
quote unquote "beat guys."
But the producers that I
got a chance to work with
were more than just beat people.
Stevie J and Dave
Hall-- these are
guys who had real fabulous
musicianship on top
of their beats.
But they had hard beats.
They knew how to knock
their heads in the studio.
My glasses are falling off.
But it was like
I was the man who
would come in with
the melody on top,
and they would have
the beat knocking.
And that's how you had that
great opposites attract
of music.
So sometimes, it was a situation
of being given a great track.
You know that "If You
Love Me" was a track
that Dave Hall presented me.
And he gave it to me on a CD.
And one morning--
I'm Jamaican-- so
know Jamaicans are
notoriously late.
I was on time today.
But Jamaicans are
notoriously late.
So one day I was on
my way late to my job
at "Essence" magazine,
I swear to God.
It just started to pour rain
as I was thinking about what
lie I could call Susan
Taylor with and tell her
I was going to be late.
Because I had every
lie in the book.
The cat, the grandmother
died, the this, the that,
blah blah blah.
So what lie can I tell?
And I swear, God was like
don't tell any more lies.
Because the rain
started pouring down.
I popped Dave Hall's track
into the CD player of my car.
And all I heard
were those chords
and the words-- the first line
of "If You Love Me" came to me.
"I don't want to rain on this
parade" inspired by the rain,
as I was late to work.
So songs can come anywhere.
I've literally had songs hit me.
One day, I was
getting a haircut.
I was in the barber shop.
And just this idea came to me.
And the barber
scratched my head,
because I was like, I
need-- I need a pen.
He's like I'm about to cut you!
And he really did cut me,
with the barber thing.
But that was when the words to
a song that I wrote for Brandy
called "One Voice," they
came to me immediately.
So I think being a songwriter
is about being open,
having something to say.
But it's also
being very attuned.
It takes being a
sensitive person.
You have to be in touch
with your emotions.
You can't be the alpha male
to be a great songwriter.
You really have to be
the sensitive male.
You have to know what you feel
and be able to articulate it,
because the women audience,
they get it right away.
But it's interesting, since
I've become a performer and not
just a songwriter, I have found
that my songs now-- especially
the songs on my
solo albums-- are
speaking to the men
very poignantly.
A lot of the men have told
me that buy my records
and they go to my concerts.
They said, thank you
for saying for me
what I didn't have the
emotional sensitivity
and that kind of courage to say.
So it's about being open.
RYAN LOREN: Great, thanks.
Thanks very much.
So can you talk
about-- obviously,
you're not just a writer.
You're also a performer,
singer, artist.
So what was the critical point
where you decided all right,
I'm going to do this.
GORDON CHAMBERS: It had been
in my mind for a long time.
Because I was in the
studio all the time
writing songs for
other artists, people
don't realize that I sang
all of those songs first.
I did the demo
for "I Apologize."
for "Missing You."
I did the demo for
"If You Love Me."
So the artists who
record the songs
were always listening
to my voice.
I would lay the lead vocals
and the background vocals.
So I always in the
studios recording.
And I knew how to
record and then
in my years as entertainment
editor at "Essence,"
I was going to all the concerts.
I've seen everyone in concert.
And I was going backstage.
I was hanging out
with the artist,
interviewing the artist.
So I was having the
best artist development
that one could ever have,
because I was seeing it
on the side of a journalist.
So I was really learning
about the business,
but then there was the fear.
I was like afraid to step
from one side to the other.
And it was something I wanted to
do, but I was afraid to do it.
And then sometimes you
just have to be open
and ask people for help.
And what happened was
I started to-- not
get afraid of making the
music, but afraid of asking
the very people
around me to help me,
because I knew that I didn't
have tons and tons of money,
but I wanted to make
a quality project.
But the day that
changed my life was I
was in the studio producing the
late and great Whitney Houston.
And I was producing
a song for her,
and I told her that I wanted
her to hit a certain note.
Then I kept telling her to
hit it higher and higher.
And then she looked
me in the face,
she said, "I think you
want to do what I do
and if that's what
you want to do,
then that's what
you need to do."
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
GORDON CHAMBERS: And I looked
at her like what did she say.
She was really in my face too.
And I was like
she's from Newark,
so when she's get
in your face, it's
kind of-- so the Newark came on
and the Brooklyn stepped back.
And I said, well,
what do you mean?
She said, I think
you want to sing.
And if that's what
you want to do,
then that's what
you should be doing.
And it was like
one of those times
when an angel speaks Word into
your life and you feel it.
And it penetrates your heart.
So shortly after that, I went to
church, the Sunday after that,
and the minister, my
minister, Pastor Trufant
in Emmanuel Baptist
Church in Brooklyn,
gave a sermon about
how not to wait.
Now is your time,
whatever you want to do.
And he talked about
how Jesus died at 36.
And many of the miracles
that you read about
were done in the last
three years of his life.
So he said, don't
wait if there's
something you want to do.
And so after Whitney
preached to me in the studio
and then Pastor Trufant preached
to me, then I said it's time.
The universe is telling me.
And I called all my
friends in the business.
And as I said, I think I'm
ready to make a solo record.
And everyone said yes.
My producer, Troy Taylor,
said come on through.
We're going to do
it in my basement.
And we went to his basement.
My friend, the publicist,
Gwendolyn Quinn, and these
are people I had all
worked with at "Essence."
But I was afraid to ask them
to help me on my own stuff.
Gwendolyn Quinn said
I'll do your PR.
Everyone I reached
out to said we
have been waiting
for this moment.
And they all helped me.
Started booking shows,
booked the very first show
at Joe's Pub.
I swear I thought 10
people were going to come.
They had to turn
200 people away.
Then the night at
the album release,
we had the album release
around the corner
at BB King's packed, packed,
almost a sold out show.
It's just from the jump.
It's as if what the
world had been waiting
for me to step
into my greatness.
And sometimes
that's what you have
to do is just listen to what the
universe is trying to tell you
and don't be afraid
to step into it.
RYAN LOREN: Perfect.
Thanks a lot.
Let's give it up for that.
Last question.
So about the music.
Talk to us about what the
last album meant to you.
That was your third album
"Sincere" and then what's next?
GORDON CHAMBERS: Every albums
gets more and more personal.
The first album was called
"Introducing Gordon Chambers,"
which featured
collaborations with friends.
Roy Hargrove, Mike Phillips,
Carl Thomas is on that album.
So the first album had
a slightly different
jazzy feeling to it.
"Love Stories" featured
a duet with Ledisi--
"To Love Again" which
became a big hit
record on a lot
of radio stations.
Then the third album, "Sincere,"
which is the most recent album.
I just wanted to
make an album that I
thought was very, very personal.
And I wanted to make
an album this time
from the perspective of
being a live performer.
The first two levels were
more from the perspective
of a songwriter that's
writing and also sings.
This one started from the
perspective of a performer.
And I want to give people
lyrically a backstage, up close
and personal emotional
look at what my life is.
I want to be more as vulnerable
as I could be with the lyrics.
And that's why the
first song of the album
is called "I'm In
The Band," because it
was being written
from that perspective.
I'm in the process of
making another album called
"Conversations
with God." and it's
going to be an
inspirational album.
But it's going to have
a spiritual tonality.
But I'm also talking
about relationships.
I'm talking about life.
And I'm just getting
more and more
vulnerable with each album.
I feel that the
R&B male tradition
has been taken over
by the sexuality.
And I want to provide
more of the sensitivity
and the sensuality into
the lyrical landscape.
RYAN LOREN: Amen to that.
So yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN LOREN: Thanks
for being here.
Everybody, I've learned a
lot from Gordon in my life.
We've known each
other a few years.
You're a role model
to many people,
GORDON CHAMBERS: Thank you.
RYAN LOREN: Thanks so
much for being here.
GORDON CHAMBERS: Thank you
for doing this-- for us here.
Thank you.
RYAN LOREN: Of course.
GORDON CHAMBERS:
See you all later!